Обов'язкова вакцинація від коронавірусу з покаранням за відмову може бути запроваджена і в Україні.
За словами начальника Держпродспоживслужби у Києві Олега Рубана, існує відповідна норма закону щодо захисту населення
від інфекційних хвороб - якщо є загроза для оточення.
Рішення може ухвалити головний державний санлікар у разі погіршення ситуації з поширенням небезпечних нових варіантів коронавірусу.
Дві дози вакцини, необхідні для повноцінного захисту від ковіду, в Україні наразі отримали лише близько трьох відсотків населення.
І причина не лише в тому, що для більшості пересічних українців вакцинація стала доступною тільки наприкінці травня.
За даними соцдосліджень, понад 40 відсотків громадян не хочуть вакцинуватися взагалі.
"Вакциноскептики" є навіть серед медиків.
У столичній Олександрівській лікарні, що на початку минулого року однією з перших почала приймати хворих на ковід,
не всі співробітники охоче спілкуються на тему вакцинації. Деякі не приховують: щеплення досі не зробили.
Скажіть, будь ласка, Ви вакцинувалися? - Ні. - Ще не готова.
Ви вже вакцинувалися? - Ні. - А чому? - Ну, поки що не хочу.
Ні, не вакцинувалася. - Чому? - Тому що я перехворіла, поки що рано.
Скажіть, будь ласка, Ви вакцинувалися? - Ні. - Чому? - Не знаю...
Натомість лікар Євген Заводовський щепився одним з перших.
Та чи варто за прикладом деяких країн ЄС все ж зробити вакцинацію від ковіду для медиків обов'язковою і в Україні?
Це питання дуже складне. Обов'язкова вакцинація може розцінюватись деякими людьми як порушення їхніх прав,
але те, що вона потрібна, особливо для медичних працівників, не викликає жодних сумнівів.
Колега Євгена Юрій Сиченко пояснює: медики, які відмовляються від вакцинації, ризикують не лише власним здоров'ям.
Медичні працівники є групою ризику по інфікуванню, враховуючи, що вони контактують з пацієнтами.
На жаль, медичні працівники можуть переносити і розповсюджувати інфекцію, навіть не знаючи, що вони інфіковані,
перебуваючи в транспорті, в громадських місцях.
- Щодо обов'язкової вакцинації - що Ви про це думаєте?
Питання складне. Я думаю, що тут потрібно проводити більше інформаційну компанію і політику - з роз'ясненням, з інформуванням.
Тим часом у Франції щеплення від коронавірусу стало обов’язковим для медиків та працівників будинків для літніх людей.
З 15 вересня ті, хто відмовиться від вакцинації, не зможуть працювати у сфері охорони здоров'я і не будуть отримувати зарплату.
Про це жорстко попередили у міністерстві охорони здоров’я Франції.
Зробивши вакцинацію обов'язковою для медперсоналу, французький уряд хоче наблизитись до досягнення мети - повномасштабної вакцинації населення.
Але поки це не вдається. Лише менше третини населення Франції отримали обидві дози вакцини.
А на перше щеплення протягом останніх тижнів записується дедалі менше людей.
Досі неохоче вакцинуються у Франції і самі медпрацівники.
Жослін Лакітен працює в цьому будинку для літніх людей під Парижем вже багато років.
Щоб захистити своїх підопічних від COVID-19, медсестра надягає маску і рукавички. Але вакцинуватись не хоче.
Я краще почекаю ще трохи, перш ніж робити щеплення. Ми просто ще недостатньо знаємо про вакцини.
Уряд на початку пандемії мав чимало прорахунків, тож я б не хотіла поспішати.
Близько половини медперсоналу в будинках для літніх людей у Франції ще не пройшли вакцинацію.
І робити щеплення для них обов'язковим було б несправедливо, вважає Лакітен.
Спочатку нас оголосили героями пандемії, а тепер ми стали паршивими вівцями,
тому що вважали за краще почекати з вакцинацією. Це мене злить.
З нею згодна і її начальниця, вважаючи, що обов'язкова вакцинація принесе будинку для літніх лише додаткові складності.
Ми повинні намагатися переконати людей, а не змушувати їх. У нас і так багато проблем з пошуком персоналу.
А кілька наших висококваліфікованих медсестер вже заявили, що вони швидше звільняться, ніж їх змусять зробити щеплення.
Але вірусологи впевнені, що масова вакцинація населення - в тому числі медсестер - має вирішальне значення.
Це єдиний спосіб запобігти перевантаженню лікарень під час наступної можливої ​​хвилі.
Вакцини забезпечують до 95 відсотків захисту від важкого перебігу хвороби.
У випадку з дельта-варіантом вірусу нам необхідний рівень вакцинації 80 або навіть 90 відсотків -
адже інфіковані цим варіантом заражають до восьми осіб. Це надзвичайно високий показник.
Французький уряд намагається прискорити кампанію з вакцинації за допомогою закликів у ЗМІ, плакатів і тимчасових центрів вакцинації.
Зробити щеплення можна вже без попереднього запису.
Рішення про обов'язкову вакцинацію також ухвалили і в Греції.
Воно набуде чинності з середини серпня - для працівників будинків для літніх людей і з 1 вересня - для всіх співробітників медичних установ.
За словами грецького прем’єра, останню главу цієї кризи у сфері охорони здоров'я можна завершити, тільки якщо кожен зробить щеплення.
Не всі з цим погоджуються. Декілька тисяч людей в Афінах та інших містах Греції вийшли на акції протесту,
вимагаючи залишити за ними право не вакцинуватися від коронавірусу.
Це наймасовіші демонстрації противників вакцинації у Греції від початку коронавірусної кризи.
Водночас обов'язкова вакцинація для лікарів з травня вже діє в Італії,
а у Ватикані ще в лютому запровадили обов’язкове щеплення для всіх жителів і тих, хто там працює.
У Німеччині ж тривають дискусії, чи варто запроваджувати обов’язкове щеплення для персоналу дитсадків та шкіл.
Відвідуючи 13 липня Інститут імені Роберта Коха, канцлерка ФРН заявила, що Німеччина поки не піде шляхом Франції.
На даний момент ми не хочемо обов'язкової вакцинації, але агітуємо за вакцинацію як таку.
І в цьому плані, заходи, які є опосередковано обов'язковою вакцинацією, звичайно, мають бути ретельно продумані.
Але наступні кілька тижнів будуть присвячені рекламній кампанії, як сказав федеральний міністр охорони здоров'я.
А потім ми продовжимо дискусію.
Чи законні у ЄС можливі вимоги обов’язкової вакцинації?
З правової точки зору, це абсолютно легітимно, але для приватних компаній.
Кожен власник може діяти відповідно до встановлених на підприємстві правил.
Тобто в ресторані, скажімо, можуть не обслуговувати людей, в яких немає щеплення.
Або не брати на роботу тих, хто не вакцинувався.
Що ж стосується державних підприємств, то ситуація дещо інша.
Приміром, німецька залізниця Deutsche Bahn зобов'язана перевозити всіх без винятку пасажирів.
Але якщо суттєво погіршиться ситуація з поширенням небезпечних варіантів коронавірусу, то тих, у кого немає щеплення,
можливо, будуть розсаджувати в окремих вагонах. Остаточного рішення ще немає.
У державних німецьких школах і дитсадках, попри деякі ініціативи, обов'язкової вакцинації немає.
Водночас приватні заклади освіти за потреби можуть запровадити вимогу обов’язкової вакцинації.